kristin i wanted to start with you on
this one because correct me if i'm wrong
i believe you were attached first
so what was it like waiting to find out
who was cast opposite you and when you
do find out are you i don't know
googling mckenzie watching some of her
films anything at all
me and clea uh kind of
you know the weird thing happens when
you're casting a movie is like you get
especially like a commercial movie which
this
big gay christmas movie is which is wild
and awesome they give you these like
lists of actresses where you're like
these are the people that are allowed to
be in your movie because they're of like
whatever
value and it was so like
well the only person like i mean not to
say that i don't
i love actresses i just there was really
like absolutely no one
for us other than mackenzie and we all
hung out
and it worked out and it just like you
know was one of those really lucky sort
of lightning in a bottle
things i can't imagine anyone else in
the in this movie
i can definitely understand that so then
mckenzie gets on board
the two of you are essentially waiting
for a year until you start filming
over the course of that year was there
ever a fear that
maybe you would have to drop out and go
to another project or were you fully
committed to this
i was really scared she was going to
stop wanting to do the movie not because
she would want to but then something
would happen
no i felt both it's what's when cleo
said she was going to push it i was like
i totally understand
i'm totally committed but also like i
don't know like
you just don't know what's going to
happen in 10 months
like i i really want to anyways i was
very dedicated but that whole year i was
like
i got i kind of only want to make it
with kristin though so
could you just like that's the version
of the movie that i signed up for and
yeah i would have been devastated i
wasn't going anywhere we were worried
about losing you
i couldn't imagine you're like a movie
any other way other than with the two of
you in the entire ensemble for that
matter but
for each of you what is something that
the other did as a scene partner
that you really appreciated and wish
more actors brought to set
oh my god i just think kristen is so
there and engaged oh you know what i'm
going to say a different answer because
i have a very complimentary answer
because
you know a lot of interviews so you can
look at those um
no what kristen did that i loved so much
because i feel this way
all the time but you kind of want to be
a professional if she would just come to
work sometimes
or we'd do a scene and she'd be like i'm
so bad
[ __ ] i hate being an actor that was so
disgusting and that's how i feel
of my life right i love
some moments and i i really like acting
and i i like
like the part but i [ __ ] hate it
to cut and then as soon as cut happens
like self-loathing descends i'm like
oh god you're so pathetic so it was
so nice to have somebody echo that and
it became like
a rallying cry i felt on set to just
like admit
how embarrassed we were sometimes and
like
frustrated we were with ourselves but it
really kind of
in a weird way opened the gates to be
big
and bold and bad which is great to have
the space to be bad in front of somebody
and not think they're going to judge you
um yeah to wrap up here
kristin i'm mighty excited for you to
eventually make your featured
directorial debut
what do you want to take from what clia
brought to this set to your own phone
that's so funny that you mentioned that
um i uh
i [ __ ] really
love how cleo works i feel so invited
and welcome to indulge in the process
and
every way that even can be like annoying
like i felt like sort of free to annoy
clia because i knew we were friends and
even though we would be like so
emotionally
impacted by every day like
and it was you know definitely like when
you do something you really care about
it's kind of really nice to know that
when you work with the right people that
like
actually kind of mckenzie just said is
that you are really free to like
sprawl and like mess up and do the right
thing and the wrong thing and
find find the weird combination of
whatever the movie ends up being
out of that and uh
yeah yeah that's like how i want to work
i really i really really loved making
this movie with these people and clea
like
made the perfect group of people for us
to really like thrive
based on what i've heard today at this
junket i very much believe what you just
said was the case
radiating off the screen in the movie so
huge congratulations to you both
and thank you again for your time today
thank you